you
i asked graham to make him go second so
i'm going to open up the work session of
the ways and means committee
and before i start
we have two substitutes this morning
for
representative lange
has been replaced by representative
howard pearl
and representative mary griffin has been
replaced by representative carol mcguire
and on mary griffin
i was finally able to
contact mary
she's at a nursing home right now
and thanks to uh representative ducette
he put me in touch with another rep that
gave me mary's direct number
and while i was talking to mary
she
asked if i would do her favor
and she wanted me to call
the nursing home
to get somebody to come into her room to
see her because she's been waiting for
so long for somebody because she
she needed him
so i
promised her i would
and i got in touch with the person that
gave me the direct number and they took
care of that
i
have a card going around i hope
everybody signs it for mary
my wife and i plan to go see her either
tomorrow or saturday so uh
and hopefully they'll cheer her up and
she'll come back i hope
now
we have 10 bills on the agenda this
morning
the last bill is house bill 10
had to do with
technical corrections for the
dra
we passed that out of this committee and
i held it
because the senate had senate bill 435
which is all there's a lot of similarity
with that bill
and waiting to see
what the senate did on that
they passed it out a committee
amended
and it was supposed to have been heard
it's going to be held
in session on the 16th of this month
so
what i'm going to do with 1063
i'm going to have jennifer do a
between senate bill 435
and house bill 1063
so we can see what the differences are
because
i looked at my folder and i'm starting
to get confused on the thing
and so
the next time we meet
we'll have that side by side and i'll
have the dra to come in
so answer any questions and and uh
make sure that
full committee understands what's going
on both with the senate bill and our
bill
and then we can decide what action we
want to take on that so we're going to
so we'll go to
is relative to taxation of income
of new hampshire
residents when working remotely or out
we're going to hold this bill
because there's more work that needs to
be done on it
they haven't been able to come up with
an amendment that
is clear
and would not
raise confusions
represented
spellsbury's working with
representatives
and
to work this out with the dra
and also the
somebody from the attorney general's
office
and hopefully
we'll have a resolution to this and
we'll
hold this until our next work session
chair
question
do we want to uh
form a subcommittee officially on this
one
uh to have some other reps uh involved
in the
in this what i'm going to do now is is
i'm having
representative spellsbury and
representing tunisian work with the
attorney general and the dra
because we're going to have very few
bills and
if we keep it as a very few bills then
i'm going to have the committee as a
whole
okay
and anybody who wants to work with
representative
uh spellsbury and jeanine
represent
alani thank you there's
a lot of
of difficult
work as i recall between
on
between dra and the ag's office about
our
tax law and to what extent we would be
violating our own tax law in this bill
and i'm wondering
if it wouldn't be better to have a
lawyer on our side
looking at it
instead of justifying definitely yes
representative spellsbury you're an
attorney right
and
yeah
i am not a lawyer
so they
we have somebody from the attorney
general's office
that that's here now yes and hi sam and
i'm assuming he's going to be working
and he doesn't have a solution at this
but he's going to
work to come up with a solution if it
can be
if it can happen
it's not an easy
i have a great deal of respect for
attorney garland but
on
it would be comforting to make sure that
there's someone from dra that's on top
of this too uh yes mr wong
yeah keane is
working the issue also great
all right any other
relative to the rates of the business
profits tax in the business enterprise
tax
and
it's on
which is amendment
which representative genevieve you want
to
talk about your
amendment yes thank you mr chairman yes
0471h to
hb1221 and very simply what
i've done here is pretty much cut out
there were two taxes being cut here the
bpt business profits tax and the
business enterprise tax the bet
i've removed
the bet
tax portion of this so there would be no
reduction to the bet tax only the
reduction to the b peep t
business profits tax from 7.6 to 7.5
percent
yields about an 8 million dollar
reduction in revenues over the year
however
not lowering the bet tax
which was estimated as about i don't
have it right in front of you about a 27
or 28 million reduction
um
could mean that the bpt doesn't
drop as much the revenue loss so
um
i guess it'd be nice if we could have um
dra maybe give us a new fiscal note
um on that piece
but um but i would argue that um if
we're going to lower any tax this is the
tax to focus on it's the most visible
tax to
businesses and and outside
people who are looking potentially to
come to new hampshire
i think it's 7.5 percent business
profits tax looks favorable
it looks favorable as compared to
surrounding states uh vermont i believe
was
i may have this backwards vermont is i
believe 8.3 and mass is 8.0 or i've got
the two mix but in any case the 7.5 is
enough of a difference that it
highlights new hampshire's business
friendly state
but we also are looking at a fairly
small drop in revenue going to 0.1
percent
i'll ask the dra if they would come up
with a new fiscal note based on on this
amendment
that they would only be doing the
reduction in the bpt and not the
reduction in the bet
how would that affect the fiscal note
and then we can handle this the next at
representative
thank you
mr chairman i've been having some
conversation
with chris shea from lbao
about trying to figure out
what
the total effect of tax cuts is
during that he he mentioned that
these constant
recalibrations of our tax rates
is making it
just about impossible to do any kind of
longitudinal
uh study of that because every single
time they do one of these they do it
based on the most recent
kafir and the kafirs do not include a
number of
of things that affect that year that
come later
they show up
a year or two later in the kafir
and
it doesn't
seem to me
that
we're going to get much out of a fiscal
note
but it also seems to me like
this is not going to
send much of a signal to
the uh people
in other states that might be thinking
of coming to us but it is sending a
signal to all of the companies that pay
that they
are going to
continue
to confront more of the load
of the business
while the companies that make big
profits
don't
thank you
thank you for your comments
representative
representative ames
yeah i just want to put this in context
uh
and by this i mean uh
revenues even though it's relatively
small
i just spent yesterday evening
at the jaffrey rindge cooperative school
which was in many ways a very heartening
session for me a strong support for the
school district
jeffrey is one of the property poor
towns in the state
30th from the bottom
along with uh you're probably about the
same place charles down a little bit
higher maybe
um
the effect of the budget
recommended by the school committee
will be about a four dollar increase in
the property tax rate
if you trace back to the
state aid to jeffrey it's been going
down
not just because of a
shrinkage of the population the school
population
because there's less of it
and
that's a big problem so
property taxes down
state
bbt
down or
keep it at least at the same level
maybe we can do something about the
property tax i've been working hard as
some know
on uh reform of our school funding
system
it depends on tax revenue from
all of our
collective
sources at the state level
we can't really do anything about that
property tax problem if we don't have
revenue um so we've got a bit maybe you
could call it a dilemma
we've got to figure this out
when i see cuts like this i think about
what's happening at the local level
in places like jaffrey
and
how it affects the school children
in the jeffrey greens uh cooperative
school district and as i say there was
strong support
a lot of uh hand-wringing and
unhappiness about the tax rate but
strong support for the school district
in that meeting which was well attended
by the way
and had both
sides of the argument well presented
so i just wanted to put that in context
thank you
thank you for your comments
representative ames
further
representing
i'd just like to add on to that last
fall there was
a virtual meeting of the bia
the annual legislative
conference
and
i listened into the part about
business taxes with businessmen
and they were
they were taught what what the
businessmen there were saying
once somebody from the audience asked a
question that was relayed to them
was
that they either didn't know
what part of what taxes they were paying
they just got given the full amount that
they were paying
or
they did know and they knew that the
property tax was the biggest part of
their tax bill
now when we're trying to help businesses
the question is are we trying to help
all businesses that are in this state
that
come from this state and are staying in
this state
or are we only trying to help the ones
that are flooding around the country
developing huge profit margins and
moving when
it seems likely that one or the other
state is offering them more
representative spillsbury
thank you mr chairman
i i very much appreciate the comments of
representative ames i share the concern
that if
taxes at the state level are cut too
substantially
it just
drives the need on the local level
further
and i will be looking
forward for ways to enhance the state's
participation in education costs so
taking in balance
for tax cut proposals that are before us
if i was to choose one that i would
support
it would be this cut of
a tenth of a percent to follow through
on a prior
series of cuts and a commitment
uh and get to a number that i think
people would
remember
and view positively so
when it comes to the proposals to cut
the
communications tax
or the bet
i i will look less favorably on those
but i'm open-minded to this one and so
if we can think of it selectively
and come to a consensus that there's one
small incremental cut
i would suggest this would be it
thank you for your comment
representative spillsbury
all right then
we will deal with this at our next work
session
repealing the tax on rentals of motor
vehicles under the meals and rooms tax
do you want to speak to this do you want
me to speak to this now or make the
motion
i'd like to make the motion actually if
we go to the executive station
then we will go into executive session
on house bill 1430
representative brown thank you why i
move
itl on house spell 1430.
representative romney you can speak to
your motion yes thank you
this call this bill calls for the
phasing out of the uh
motor vehicle rental tax
going down some of you on this committee
i think i'm looking to my right and to
my left here
were around when this tax was put into
place uh post claremont decision and
when they were looking for funding for
education
it's not a big dollar amount it's only
about eight million dollars what we're
talking about
but believe it or not
uh
the majority here in this committee uh
agrees with what's a lot of what
representative ames was saying
uh and that we we want to tread lightly
on on the cuts that we do
and this is one that we don't
don't think it's it's worth cutting
there's various reasons for that first
off
every other state has this car rental
tax
and our 8.5
car rental tax is
quite modest compared to other states i
mean really modest
and i you heard me speak about this in
one of our other uh meetings about about
how other states tack on all sorts of
other fees on top of their tax and we we
just we just haven't pure eight point it
was nine it's going to be 8.5 percent
so quite modest
now enterprise who testified
claimed that more locales rent than out
of staters uh my locals i say rent than
out of staters
and that may be true but when we probed
a little bit
it turns out that a lot of those
in-state
renters are renting cars for
uh if their car is wrecked or if it's in
for maintenance
uh and guess what and many of those
especially the car
the insurance is paying for it not the
individual
so
so i have no problem continuing the tax
for taurus and and out of state business
i think it's just returning the same
favor that the other states do to us um
i mean it's
and they and they
they treat us
wow and i again like i said i used to
travel just about every week so i i know
i pretty much know all the rates in all
these other states
then we also heard from our state
treasurer
at the economic briefing
several weeks ago
and one of the one of the key things we
have to worry about our bond rating
and one of the one of the things that
that the bond rating agencies like to
see is the diversity of taxes
that we have to buffer against ups and
downs and certain segments of the
economy
so this is just one small piece of that
diversity
again six to seven i said eight million
before it's really six to seven million
uh that we're talking about with this
so if one if if business taxes are going
for whatever reason certain segments of
our economy drop at least we have some
other sources of revenue that's why we
like to have
different sources of revenue and that's
the same logic
that we i think we had with the uh
telecommunication tax again that wasn't
a big tax
but it was it's something that
we we used to balance our portfolio of
taxes if you will
so um
so with that
and and given all of what we have been
talking about in this committee for the
last couple of months
do we still have all these unknowns
about
about where the ppp refunds are going to
come in
uh where the new provisions for the
credit carry forwards are going to come
in in terms of dollars that uh we're
gonna have to give back to
to the various businesses that are uh
now we put a limit on how much could be
carried forward
uh now that was just the first step
that's gonna continue we're gonna
continue cranking that down over time
and then of course the the phasing out
of the stimulus money
uh and
we have to really see what what that's
done to propping up our economy and it
could be uh
you know the revenues may not be flowing
as as fast as before so
with that i i would suggest that we all
vote itl on this and i think it's the
prudent thing to do thank you
thank you representative romney
any further questions or comments on the
motion of itl
represent ames
just to say that i i support the motion
and um
i would also add that um
i think it was a year ago or so that we
worked on this uh
this tax and uh made sure it was
broadly applicable to comparable
transactions and um throughout that
discussion i don't remember any effort
to uh bring to our attention the need to
uh repeal the tax
uh i have not heard that
said to me you know that hasn't been
said to me
uh during all my time here it seems to
be a tax that uh
that exists and most people accept it as
the reality of life no matter where you
go you pay a tax when you rent a car and
this is the new hampshire's version
so i would leave it the way it is
thank you
thank you representative ames
i agree with you representative ames has
been around for a while since 1999 when
they had this special
committee to salt resolve
the klamath
education
and that was
that tax on automobile rentals was added
at that point in time
so saying no further questions i asked
the clerk to call
the vote
on the motion of itl
on house bill 1430. thank you mr chair
we'll begin the roll call vote on house
bill 1430. the motion is itl we'll start
representative mcguire yes
representative
yes representative doucette yes
representative pearl yes the clerk votes
yes
representative genigean
yes representative nunes yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative tudor yes representative
aaron
i got you down for two yes votes
representative
representative ames
representative the honorable
representative thomas c schomburg mr
clerk i vote yes thank you sir
i appreciate your patience thank you
we're back back online representative
gomarlo yes
representative murphy yes
chairman major yes
the vote being 19 to nothing
the motion of itl passes
and without objection we go on consent
the next bill
is house bill 1450-fn
encoding agricultural resources under
the land and community heritage
investment program
representative ames
are we still in executive session
we're in executive session okay i move
itl
on house bill 14. who's itl
second by
representatively
representative angel want to speak to
your motion yeah i would simply say that
uh
first i i commend uh
the um proponent of this bill the prime
sponsor and bringing it forward for
discussion and examination
we also
had the benefit of
an impressive and serious
set of presentations by people who know
this
subject and particularly the
agricultural side of uh
of this subject
far better than we do and that was
helpful and thoughtful
and productive
i think uh the the the reason that i
is twofold i think
first the elkship program
writ large it has wide support
in new hampshire
it's achieved somehow an appropriate
balance
in its funding mechanism and in what it
does
and it does good work i mean you really
don't hear any
any criticism of what it's doing
it does good work
and i'm concerned that we may
upset that balance
and that
achievement of
a level of excellence that we can all
support
by going forward with this bill at this
time testimony from commissioner jasper
uh indicated that the agricultural
interests
that this bill seeks to
bring forward are definitely considered
within the frame of the current
legislation
so i just assume leave it leave it at
that
and
leave the program to march along and
maybe at another time it will be
appropriate to
both uh
provide
an emphasis on agriculture
and provide additional funding but i
don't think this is the time so that's
that's it thank you
thank you representative
any further questions or comments on
saying none then i'll ask the clerk to
call the vote on
itl on house bill 1450.
thank you mr chair uh just quickly for
the record i don't have who seconded
that motion by representative robertson
we will begin the voting with
representative abrami yes
maguire
yes hillary
yes ducette yes pearl yes bursting votes
yes genigen yes
nunes yes spillsberry yes tudor yes
aaron
yes
army yes
representative ames yes
malloy
thomas c schomburg
representative schamberg voces thank you
it's hacking phillips not yet
chairman major yes
the vote being 19-0 the motion of itl
passes
i see no objection so it will appear on
we're still in executive session
relative to the business profits tax
applicable to certain large low
wage employers
representative
bernstein thank you mr chair i move that
house bill 1478 is inexpedient to
legislate
representative bernstein moves
and experience the legislate do we have
representative bernstein you want to
speak to a motion
this bill made me recall
it evoked memories of my grandmother and
i'd like to share a short story with you
in the mid 60s maybe 1966 or so my
grandmother took my brother sister and i
to a nursing home where my
great-grandmother was
unfortunately they only allowed two kids
in there once so my brother and sister
being older than me got to go into the
nursing home to visit my great
grandmother
they left me in the car with the back
window rolled down a little bit so i
could get some air
when they came out after visiting my
great-grandmother they each had
a full hershey bar
these aren't the little hershey bars the
what they call fun size which i don't
know why they call the little ones the
fun size
but uh i guess my grandmother saw the
look in my eyes and she insisted that my
brother and sister each give me half of
the hershey bar
my brother objected saying but that'll
mean alan gets a full hersh my
grandmother interrupted and said don't
you be selfish or slap you down so they
each had to give me half of their
hershey bar
well this bill house bill 1478
is
i understand
where it's coming from it's compassion
and the intent is good
but it it's
the bill is sort of it's so flawed it's
it's nonsensical and it negates the
intent of the bill
um what this bill does is
for any employer with more than 100
employees if any one employee
makes 15 or less
it subjects that
business
to a surtax
raising the business
profits tax from seven point six percent
to eight percent
um
there are
many deficiencies with the bill and i'll
highlight the main one and that is this
is clearly unconstitutional
uh specifically when considering the
clause included in part two article five
of the new hampshire constitution
regarding equal and proportional tax
rates
for that's the primary reason i'll spare
all the other reasons because i just
can't get by the constitutionality of
this for that reason i suggest that this
bill be ito'd
thank you representative bernstein any
other
comments
on the motion
saying none i'll ask the clerk to call
the vote on the motion of itl on house
bill 1478.
thank you mr chair we will begin the
voting with representative abrami yes
representative mcguire yes
yes
yes pearl yes bursting votes yes
janiggian yes nunes yes spillsbury yes
tudor yes aaron yes
almi
yes yes
representative ames yes
malloy
i have you down as a yes vote
representative tucker yes representative
gomarlo
no
representative murphy yes
chairman major yes
the motion
passes with a vote of 18 to 1 of itl on
1478. representative model do you have a
binary report
i do and i object to consent consent
calendar that's why i asked you the
question thank you
the next says house bill 14
94 relative to property tax exemptions
concerning certain communication
we're still in executive session
representative
thank you mr chairman
i uh move inexpedient to legislate
on
hp 1478.
representation i'm sorry um
itl on house sculpture 1494.
yes
i need a second
second
representative schamberg
representative
you can expect your motion thank you mr
chairman um
this bill
um while well-meaning and i think we had
some testimony that suggested that
if the communications tax was cut
for uh telecom and cable companies
it would help result in
bringing
high-speed services to more households
however there's nothing in the bill that
requires that and there's nothing that
suggests that that would have to happen
so
the the other side of this is that
cutting
taxes on those companies
will result in
in potentially
towns and cities having to raise taxes
on other
entities and taxpayers
in addition to that there's a question
of constitutionality with this bill
you know it seems it looks like it would
not pass constitutional muster given
that you are
selecting certain companies not to have
to pay
property taxes so for these reasons
i
move itl on this bill
thank you
representation and
further comments
saying none i'll ask the clerk to call
the vote
thank you mr chair
the motion is ito for house bill 1494.
we will begin the voting with
representative abrami yes representative
mcguire
yes
representative yes
pearl
yes bursting votes yes genigen yes nunes
yes spillsberry yes tudor yes aaron yes
representative army yes representative
ames yes representative thomas c
southworth
i appreciate that
i'm glad you're looking out for me
representative malloy
representative thomas c schomburg
yes
representative tucker
representative murphy yes the chairman
major yes
the vote been
19-0 on the motion of itl
that
passes on house bill 1494.
i see no objection so
house bill 1494 will go on the consent
calendar
mr chairman
yes
i'm not sure i know that hacken phillips
was hoping to be here by now she's
testifying somewhere
waiting probably to testify on
whether
but i think we could go forward
since we have an understanding about her
input
yes thank you
mr i spoke to her earlier
okay
let's get a motion first okay executive
session
representative romney
i move uh any speeding to legislate on
house bill 1509
representative romney
let me speak to your motion thank you mr
chair
this bill terminates the uh fm frm
victims contribution recovery fund
and i guess it would cancel out all of
the the
funding that's
already been passed in
and
this is the financial resources mortgage
frm victims contribution fund that was
established a couple of years ago
but just funded uh this past budget with
5 million fiscal year ending june 30th
of 22 and another 5 million
for fiscal year
ending june 30th 2023.
from the testimony there is no question
that the state failed at its oversight
responsibility thus leading to the
failure of frm and harm to its investors
this 10 million dollar combination uh
the two five millions
in no way covers for all the losses
incurred by the investors in this fund
if we pass this bill to repeal this fund
and the money already appropriated it
would be a classic bait and switch
by the state of new hampshire
which in my opinion would be an
embarrassment to the state if we did
this
please vote itl and i would appreciate
your vote on this thank you
representative
alame
thank you
on
we are
the lawyers in our group cannot remember
that any state has ever
compensated
investors
that lost their shirts
without being forced to buy a lawsuit
but on
those of us in
in
on the democratic side of the aisle
believe that it is too late at this
point to stop the process of
distribution that would be
an even worse precedent
to
stop distributing once we have sent out
information to investors that this
exists and that they should apply
so we are voting itl
with the majority
and uh there will be a
short statement about some members
feeling that we should not stop the
process at this point
added to the blurb thank you
and that will happen
represent ames
yeah i just wanted to add that this i
see this as a unique situation
that uh grew out of uh
a bad behavior by
certain people in the private sector
and then a uh
confused and discombobulated and uh
and harmful response from the state side
and uh
and that led to years of uh
effort by investors
who had been scammed to
somehow recover some funds and ended
i think too late effort to try to repeal
what was decided
last year so i stand with that
uh repeal
but i also want to note that the state
has taken significant action
since um
since this came to light in the early
part of the 2000s
and we heard about that we had testimony
and that was good
the
looking forward we can be hopeful that
this won't happen again but i would
reiterate that this is a unique
situation and i would expect that
investors need to keep their eyes open
state guidance to bail them out if their
thank you representative ames
representative schamberg
uh thank you mr chairman notwithstanding
what the ranking member
and the vice ranking member have said
uh
one point
i did ask the ag
has this ever gone to a court of record
uh if the state was liable
and
were they responsible and both times
not to his knowledge
and
i sort of get an answer to that one
to my question the second part is
uh
ronald reagan
president reagan said
uh
party
his party does not believe in bailouts
he believes in personal responsibility
and he said that the approach
that they were dealing with
back then
on a particular item
even though i'm going to vote with our
the state is providing charity to these
individuals that should have
taken more personal responsibility
thank you
further class representing yearly
thank you mr chair um
i've had some experience taking cases to
court uh not as a
lawyer but as supporting
lawyers
and
my
observation has been
that when somebody loses in court they
lose more
than if a settlement out of court had
been made
and i look at this uh
arrangement that the state has made
under frm as the settlement out of court
saving the state
a lot of money
as
we heard in testimony and testimony and
testimony because of some malfeasance on
the part of
various state operators which would have
most likely have
wound up with a
uh i'll use somebody else's language
from new york huge
settlement
but uh
so
i'm in favor of the itl motion thank you
thank you representative any further
comments representative murphy thank you
mr chairman um
of all the bills this session this is
the one that's probably given me the
most angst personally
for two reasons one is that
i was
to be consistent i voted last summer
to support the amendment to eliminate
the 10 million dollars
for support of this fund
in the amendment uh 1064-h
i'm also
of the same opinion as ronald reagan and
representative schamberg that personal
responsibility and
the accountability of
of the state needs to be considered if
there is any malfeasance on their part
but the state as a bailout you know
mechanism for
investors that
lost money to me is a horrible
precedent so
in in large part i am
concerned by myself being inconsistent
because i will probably vote with the
majority in our our caucus
but it does give me angst to
vote in a sense for bailout of investors
and also to be inconsistent with my
previous vote of last summer thank you
thank you representative murphy
further
comments
representative
allen
thank you this one is
more personal but it's an example of the
problems
that our attorney general's office has
had when i arrived and still has
it's
understaffed
and
purposefully i think and it
does not provide consumer protection
support to the ordinary citizen of new
hampshire
as an example there was a
fraudulent roofer
that
took in
i think it was eight people on our side
of the connecticut river
three of them in my complex
two of them it took the roof off
and then didn't come back and the others
it had taken that he'd taken the deposit
and he didn't come back
there were i think 28
victims on the other side of the
connecticut river
the attorney general of vermont went
after the guy
got him locked up got him condemned to
restitution for the vermonters
nothing was done on our side
of the river
and
it was a significant loss for some of my
neighbors
on
and not to mention that they had to live
through the winter with a plastic
and
i do not think that any other state
probably does as bad a job of consumer
protection for
multiple cases like that
as we do
and it's because
they don't have enough people to work it
they also don't have enough people to
help with the condominium problems
which is one of my pet peeves
so
thank you
just getting it off my chest
thank you representative
almi represented ames
yeah just a note uh
on this question of inconsistency i too
uh suffer the
uh inconsistency angst but uh
not so much because i think uh once
she's it's sort of the bait and switch
metaphor that uh representative ramy
used uh
i think that's the metaphor he used
um
we've started down a road
we've uh
gone past that vote and started up a
program it's in place
they're uh so they've solicited
applications
they're
processing applications if they've come
in
we've started down a road and it's it's
just too late to close that barn door to
use another metaphor
and
then so off we go and i think we go with
a lot of concerns but that's where we
are thank you
thank you representative ames
any further comments
saying none i'll ask the court to call
the vote on the motion of itl on house
bill 1509
thank you mr chair we will begin the
voting with representative abrami yes
representative mcguire
yes representative owery yes
representative doucette
representative pearl yes
the clerk votes yes representative
genigean yes
representative nunes yes representative
spillsbury yes representative tudor yes
representative aaron yes
representative almi
yes
representative ames yes representative
malloy
representative thomas c schomburg yes mr
clerk thank you sir representative
representative murphy
yes
i figured this off
i couldn't hear you he said that
no objection
but i was cautioning the emotion maker
and the seconder that this will likely
i think
i'm going to put this on the regular
calendar
mr
chairman if you're going to do that we
might have a lengthy discussion
because we we might have to talk on our
side of it as well and then there would
be the side of the people that did the
motion
okay then i'll reverse my decision on
that
and
put it on the consent calendar and if it
gets pulled off then we will have the
discussion
thanks
thank you representative me you're
welcome
that is going to be we're going to
representative spellsbury um
house bill 1524
establish a national service alumni
attraction and retention discussion now
by representative schamberg
representative schamberg you want to
speak to your amendment i will defer to
representative pillsbury
we're in work session now right
so i'm not prepared to make a motion at
this time
i think it's important to hear
representative schamberg explain his
amendment
suggest that
we have serious reservations about this
and i think those reservations
will carry to the amendment as well but
uh
i think we need to hear
what you've done and how you believe it
thank you representative spillsbury mr
chairman representative spells
chamber
thank you mr chairman uh
what initially was a
i thought an easy bill
i should never think that
representative ames pointed out some
drafting questions on the original bill
and
uh
went to the sponsor
and
we drafted the first
amendment
and
the majority ranking member did point
out some things to us because of her
institutional knowledge
that maybe we should look at this
redrafting again
and we did that we came up with a second
one
and then
there were some more questions
just about word placement
uh who had responsibility who has
controlled the money
and what we took out was the arp of
funds the actual wording of the arpa
funds out of a
roman numeral ii
and uh
thought we had it done when we came up
with this amendment but there's been
some question about
uh
the amount of money to be hereby
appropriated and i would like the
opportunity to go back to the ols
and
ask them to look at how the money will
be appropriated
it looks as it's a demand
versus
an approach of
a decision by
the governor and the executive council
and that's where
the sponsor and i believe it should be
um
there were two words that had to be
added in
the
original
section four roman numeral one
permissible use had to be established so
the workforce development word on line
nine
and the word education had to be added
and then
this is where the arpa money was stated
in the beginning when representative
ames talked about the drafting
it is now a generic
approach
of
additional gifts grants donations or
bequeaths
or any federal state or local funds
that made it more than what was said
before it just said it shall come from
arpa which we did not the sponsor did
not
wish that and does not wish it to come
out of the general fund also
and then
put an amount in
but is it but put a statement is hereby
with certain federal funds you can't say
you must
and so we'd like to take it back mr
representative spillsbury for
maybe a fourth redrafting which may
clear up some of the issues that you had
brought up
we're going to hold this for further for
a further work session and you'll get an
opportunity to do that representative
romney representative
almi followed by representative romney
thank you
i'm
a little confused
by this on the process that is
set up is that
the money is appropriated
on and then the governor shall determine
if there are discretionary funds
appropriated in arba
this was cleared with the sponsor
and
it also um
what it means
and what has happened in the past is
that the governor
if he decides that there isn't any money
in there because he wanted to use it for
something else
can just not do it
and that can be a problem but the
and it's not such a problem for them
because the governor
has a
member as a person on their uh
their board
who
is constantly involved with what they're
doing
and
and the governor seems to approve of
this
so
it is
what we're talking about is taking money
from arpa that will disappear if it's
not used
on
and
on putting
this
not very big amount
three-quarters of a million dollars for
over three years
into
a board that
is
trying to increase its work with
employers around the state to keep
people
that are valuable to the state of new
hampshire in new hampshire working
and
includes some help in
americorps and
return peace corps volunteers
getting the further education that will
make them more valuable
so
it seemed like a very good bang for the
book
and the buck isn't ours the buck is the
federal government's
thank you representative romney
just the two comments on this
uh
i think somewhere in here you should say
that the the
state treasurer creates a fund
and it's administered by the
commissioner department of
administrative services but it's really
the fund is created and maintained by
the treasurer
i've had other bills where that language
so you may want to check with
ols on that
and uh and then that
unless it's in there i i just scanned it
here i didn't i didn't see it but
and then the other thing
when i read line 23
22 and 23
it does sound like state money this is
the sum of 750 000 for fiscal year
ending june 30th 23
is hereby appropriated
are we are we talking state money
we are not talking state money yeah when
i read that it sounds like state money
drafting okay if i could the drafter put
in
on if there is not enough money in arpa
it's going to come out of the general
fund and we took it out
okay
but i'm just saying i i don't know that
it just
casual reader here it just sounds like
it's going to be state money so i'd i'd
make sure
it's not that
representative romney in line seven it
says there is hereby established in the
state treasury international
okay there we go thank you
representative scanned too fast
thank you mr chair
so i have a question to the committee
i'm new at this obviously
um
is there any other organization that is
you know similar to the peace corps or
americorps
there any other organizations that we
we would have to check that out and
represent elmi yeah
we have i don't i forget about 350
dedicated funds at this point
some of them are just
donations and most of those are dead
funds that we're weeding out as we go on
a lot
most of them are getting money either as
a percentage of
some
fee or some tax
and
or they got an appropriation from the
state or a federal or other source
that frequently was one time and is
meant to be revolving or meant just to
finish after a while
and this one the the people who got
who are asking for the money the board
what do they call that board
the
volunteer new hampshire board
on
they
went into this
expecting that it was going to last them
three years
and that during that time they would
develop
enough more contacts within the business
community
that they would be able to keep going on
representative bernstein followed by
representative murphy thank you mr chair
on february 2nd the the prime sponsor of
the bill made of reference to 750 000
over three years and representative
ahmed you just referenced that twice
where is that language in the bill or
actually the way that we did it they
were saying either 250 a year or 750
and we just decided okay
give them the 750
they're going to use it over three years
if there's still some left at the end
since it's a dedicated fund until we get
around to
to repealing it at some point and it
would uh
it would
probably be used in the fourth year
and if
they decided to go two years they could
but to be clear the appropriation is a
one-time appropriation of 750 000 and is
it possible for that
money
to be depleted
before three years or
two years or one year
i should think it could be
the governor's
person on the
council would probably have a problem
with that
thank you
representative murphy thank you mr
chairman um
in response to representative aaron's uh
uh question i i i don't think we are
supporting
the various organizations by the wording
here it says
americorps alumni
returned peace corps volunteers
people have completed one or more terms
in the civil service so i think what
we're really trying to do is not support
those organizations but attract and
bring back those qualified and dedicated
individuals so that to me makes a
difference as in the sense that we're
not supporting an individual
organization but more an attraction of
trying to attract good qualified people
representative tucker yes i think
representative aaron you weren't here to
hear the testimony
that began the process
and i don't remember the name of the
report but there was a report on how do
we keep
good people here in new hampshire who
are leaving
and there's a lot of effort to
understand why it is that we have
trouble attracting and keeping young
younger workers
and there was a report and it suggested
this kind of process
that would allow
small amounts of money to be matched
for educational grants that would keep
this very group of people
many of whom leave so it it wasn't so
much that it was started on the basis
that there was a precedent already
for such a fund but that this was a way
to meet today's demands
of young people to make new hampshire
more attractive so it was a workforce
development
report
and does anyone remember the name of the
yes
i've got it in my hand it was passed out
to us i think in the white folder that
they sent us
represent aaron
yes thank you mr chair thank you for
that representative tucker um
are we aware of any other states that um
do this sort of um
you know have this sort of uh
at the mr chair
at the present time know that new
hampshire would be the first in the
nation
to address
and approach it this way thank you
representative spillsberg
thank you mr chairman
i i think there are a number of uh
questions and arguments that could be
made
whether this is a good idea in the first
place to be the first state to do this
and
what exactly motivates it um i i
understood from representative wilhelm's
testimony that this was driven largely
by workforce development objectives but
a careful read of the
commission's report which he authored
i think reaffirms my
impression
that in fact
the peace corps program itself and the
americorps program itself
are substantially driven by workforce
development objectives and it's the
experience
of spending two years overseas in the
peace corps or a year or more in
americorps
that in fact prepares
a young person to be
attractive
in the workforce or to be better
prepared to get the most out of further
education
representative wilhelm's
report is really quite effective in that
respect
and
there's another
extensive piece that was also included
in that packet
that
primarily dwells on how well prepared
those individuals are when they emerge
from the program
so i'm i'm suspecting that
what really is the motive behind the
bill
is
the attraction and retention the
question of
um
you know not even so much whether
they've enhanced
workflow but can we keep them in the
state well who are they and
you know one would hope that
new hampshire
uh youth who go through this program
would return to the state
one might hope that
people who come from other states and
spend a year here in americorps
choose to stay i think those are really
valid objectives
but i think that
it still raises the question whether
this is the right mechanism
and whether they should be truly singled
out so for example if we're going to
dedicate a certain amount of funds
what's the distinguishing
feature
that allows us to target the money to
these individuals but exclude
a wide array
of young people whose prospects are
equally bright and whose
presence in the state would be equally
valuable
i don't see that distinguishing criteria
in the bill in effect i think the bill
suffers
from a lack of
specific and useful parameters it really
how much
for how long
for what purpose
with what conditions
with what performance expectations or
requirements and what outcomes
if i as a benefactor chose to establish
a scholarship
fund
i would lay out those criteria and
they're completely absent in this bill
which leaves me to believe it's just
going to be a wide open rule-making
exercise so i think the bill has flaws
and
and i would just
go back to representative alame's point
the
the idea that the funds can be up to 250
per year for three years
and would come from arpa funds
is clear in your statement but it is not
thank you representative spellsbury
uh representative
thank you i'd like to point out we are
talking
about a small organization which has
ties to the peace corps volunteers and
the
americorps
alumni
from around the country as well as here
on and that this committee after a huge
amount of work
and uh
on arguing
approved
an enormous amount of money
to go to
the army
program in manchester
uh for similar purposes
but specifically for
iowa uh
uh how do you call it bio biomechanical
advanced manufacturing regenerative
and we still don't have a report on that
further comments
then
[Music]
we have some work to do on this bill
put it into the pile
tax expenditure yes um
representative romney is on the tax
expenditure committee
and uh
since representative alame has asked
about a report represent representative
representative ames is aware of this
in our next meeting on the 25th of
february
we have invited army and finally tracked
down the right person
maureen tui
uh who
deals who would know something about the
tax
break part that we gave
and then we invited james
uh key
james key
wallace
who knows something about the tuition
forgiveness part of this
so
uh we hope to
it's amazing
i don't really know how many people have
how many small companies have taken
taken advantage of the program
the department of revenue
kind of hints that
yes
there's at least one because they won't
tell us but since they won't tell us
it's under 10.
now i called the commissioner the other
day
in revenue on department review
and i said can you help us out a little
bit here i know i know we're not allowed
to
but it'd be helpful if we you're not to
give us names companies or anything like
that just to have a dollar amount
how many uh you know or uh how many
companies how much
how much of a tax break have we given to
date
from this program
and then when i talked to uh key wallace
he said they just got the rules through
yeah
so he's right now zero of taking pace of
the trip so but if anybody's interested
and want to hear it because it's nine
o'clock on the on the uh 25th
uh we're we're bringing the right people
in the room to give us an update
i think it will be like i think all
these things are live streamed yes
and interestingly enough i was i managed
to because
representative and i
and uh senator geider are also on the uh
charitable gaming committee
i i managed to get us in the same room
and
you know this is a house committee
so we're not allowed to use the senate
room but we're going to use the center
room
for an hour and a half before the
they were so gracious enough to allow us
to use the senate room that we're going
to be in for the other
so
um anyway if you're interested in it
it's on the 25th i'll make another
announcement before we get there thank
you
i would recommend that you either
do it virtually
or go to it because it's something that
we ought to be aware
of what the results
of this bill that we passed i think
four years ago
and
right and so
we need to get what's the feedback has
it worked
and that okay
uh any further discussion on
saying none that's
we're going to discuss it at the future
work session which hasn't been set yet
and the last bill
relative to the old
that has
we're going to continue working on that
there's a lot of issues that are open
on that
uh we're not ready
not unless you want to either kill it or
go to interim study
but we have
four
weeks
left
and i think we need to spend some time
understanding this better
and what i want to do when we do meet
next time review this bill
put down what questions you have
so that
we can take action and
if you have questions let me know ahead
of time so we can try to get the right
the big one coming our way is going to
be the marijuana bill that we have to
come up with
oh yeah
we're going to be having uh a bill
referred to us
after it passes the full house next week
and that's the marijuana bill
and that
that marijuana bill has to do with the
state
operating
businesses
that only sell marijuana so the state
will operate like they do with liquor
they'll own
the marijuana stores
and they will sell and get the markup
and they will
contract with the growers and the
growers have to
which provides the material
have to be
in new hampshire
and
they also estimate that
profits that they
come up with could easily be 250 million
dollars or more
so we need to understand
those issues
we're not going to deal with the policy
but we're going to deal with
where
the
it's a money issue how are they raising
the funds
and all the issues associated with that
and then
because the federal government doesn't
allow
money
associated with marijuana sales to go
through the regular banking system
if they can't come up with one they want
to generate their own banking system
so
yeah
it's going to be very interesting and
that that'll be coming to us can i
interject a few things on that yes yeah
thank you mr chair
yeah the banking thing we've already we
already talked to representative hunt
about this
because he he covers banking his first
reaction is no
no way
but you know it can't go to two
committees but i think we'll probably
have representative that was that was
the last minute amendment to the bill
uh and the banking uh the uh head of the
banking bank association approached me
that they have big concerns about going
to state bank that's when i talked to
hunt
he has concerns too but danny that's
that's that and then uh
so the way it's going to work is that
there'll be private growers
x number to be unlimited marketplace
driven that's going to that are going to
generate
business profits taxes
and they're going to be manufacturers
that are going to make edibles
that would also be free enterprise that
would be
the only thing that's going to be retail
is going to be these actual stores it'll
be set up
and organizationally they have it set up
like the liquor commission under the
liquor commission actually it's going to
be liquor it's going to change the name
of the liquor commission the
liquor and
liquor and cannabis commission
that's all in the bill
we'll be getting into those details
right so when we get the bill
and
what was
told to us is that at least half the
funds would come from the sale of these
so-called cookies
and so we'll need to get i know myself
i'll need to get educated i don't know
about the younger people
so we're going to have brownies
but rather represent
thank you mr chairman uh just to for
disclosure i'm a co-sponsor of that bill
and i look forward to the discussion on
this there is a way that
this can move forward being handled by
the state and also benefit all the
people of the state of new hampshire and
those discussions will come forth with
uh the presentation that will be given
to you uh i think this is going to be a
very interesting hearing
representative
thank you if we're going to be talking
about a state bank shouldn't we be
talking to the banking commissioner yes
there's a lot of a lot of issues
uh we don't have the bill yet but i just
want to let you know it's coming
so listen next week it'll probably on
the floor they'll be discussing it
and uh
we shouldn't be discussing it if we
uh
do you have any idea when we might be
coming back in to do some committee work
here any rough idea yes the week after
the next next week is a busy week
and so to be the
wake right after that
so don't wait until then
to
come up with your questions or
recommendations let me know if there's
somebody
that we need to contact
to
meet with us at the work session so we
representative
right
uh 15
65. i think i keep on getting that
number wrong
i really think there must be some way we
could talk with a member of the
commission
besides
on
agreed by the commission is their only
spokesperson
but i do think it would be useful if we
could
other than the attorney general's office
to also talk with us about it
let me work on that yeah mr chair
mr chair
i i agree and i i would also like to see
um representatives from other counties
come and talk to us
um
because we've we've heard from people
from sullivan county as well you know
solely
uh i know that there are probably some
uh representatives from coast or
cheshire or some of the other counties
that might want to weigh in on this
okay i can work on
finding some folks if you like
i'm finding that very difficult because
in my own county
on
most of the people who should have known
about this don't know anything about it
and
and it's my on
senior county commissioner who
is the chair
for on
for all of the county commissioners in
new hampshire and signed
several letters
that aren't entirely
in agreement with each other about this
and
she's changed her phone number and i
don't know how to reach her
i guess i'm going to have to try at the
do what you can on the counties out and
see if i can get somebody from the
commission okay and if i may i would
like to work with you representative
valmie on this if if we can come to
yeah there's some additional work that
needs to be done some of the comments
that were made
i
asked
to verify them and
got an entirely different story from the
other side
regarding who was participating who
wasn't participating and
and
there's
any more information a lot more
we have our work cut out for us on this
then that was the last bill we had to
discuss
i didn't realize we'd be through so
early
so
and
remember next week we have a session on
wednesday and thursday the session
o'clock wednesday
thank you
we are adjourned
you everybody sign the card
the woman who stands so you know
they assign people big minutes
she's the one
you know what
i
i have two emails and i'm getting over
because it's probably not even they
don't even know where we need it right
now
oh
um
you